traditionally horror is in the genre
that depends on digital trickery taking
a practical approach is often not only
cheaper but more effective when it comes
to unnerving an audience and horror
movies rarely enjoy the freedom of a big
budget especially when the big Studios
aren't involved
advances in technology in recent years
have made convincing visual effects far
more accessible however to the point
that even low-budget productions can
take advantage green screens are now
commonplace on horror sets and if you
strip away all the special effects what
you're left with isn't very scary at all
hollow man paul verhoeven 'he's hollow
man fell well short of recouping the 95
million dollar production budget at the
domestic box office and it took a
hammering in the media with 27 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes but even the harshest
critics of the film admitted that the
special effects were impressive
Verhoeven told DVD talk we really tried
to link the special effects shots with
the actors as much as possible we wanted
coherence between the special effects
and the actors so people would accept
the effects as part of the actors scene
Jerome Chen senior VFX supervisor at
Sony Pictures Imageworks told FX Guide
that film was all done with roto mation
off the performance of Kevin Bacon no
motion capture just hard thousands of
hours of labor the ring gore Verbinski's
box-office smashed the ring kick-started
Hollywood's obsession with Japanese
horror during the mid-2000s Naomi Watts
plays a seattle journalist who's
investigating an urban legend about a
videotape that kills anyone who watches
it in seven days when her son
unwittingly pops ed tape into their VHS
player the pair are haunted by Samara
who crawls out of a well and straight
through the television but the look of
the vengeful ghost was the in-camera
work of special-effects makeup artist
Rick Baker he said I think the scariest
thing about tomorrow for me anyways is
not knowing what's under that hair
crimson peak guillermo del toro is the
shape of water marks a return to form
for the director whose 2015 Gothic
romance crimson peak tanked hard at the
box office
the latter relied on what VFX supervisor
Chris mcclain called practical hybrids
for the most part mixing green screen
with creature builds one example can be
seen towards the end of the movie when
Edith has a farewell moment with Thomas
and her fingers passed right through his
face the conjuring 2 James Wan the
conjuring in 2013
was the first film in what would later
evolve into a shared movie universe
encompassing the Annabelle series as
well as the nun and The Crooked Man
visual effects artist David riddlin
worked on a few shots for the first
conjuring movie rendering some everyday
items that you probably didn't realize
receipt GI including the scariest
bedsheet ever VFX artist Didier koenings
was hired to take care of the little
details in 2016 s the conjuring to
removing security cameras and altering
buildings to make the 1970 set look
authentic the thing on action the beast
comes forward it's gonna be on fire a
prequel to John Carpenter's 1982 horror
classic of the same name 2011 s the
thing follows the plight of a doomed
group of scientists who discover a
living alien buried deep in a flock of
Antarctic ice in the ice
the film's VFX supervisor yes Burke
cloves bird described his process to the
art of VFX saying as the teeth of the
alien mouth rip the skin we see the
inside tentacles pushed through while
Juliet's head is forced towards her back
gross Godzilla director Gareth Edwards
landed on Hollywood's radar with his
visually impressive low-budget breakout
monsters in 2010 and the following year
he was offered the job of rebooting
Godzilla Edwards was initially concerned
that signing on for a Hollywood
blockbuster meant he would have to
relinquish control to a certain extent
but the studio's reaction to the first
teaser trailer he cut put his mind at
ease he told FX Guide I just wanted to
do what I thought would give me
goosebumps
Edwards brought in VFX House MPC to make
the trailer and they went on to render
several set pieces in the final film
including Godzilla causing havoc in San
Francisco Bay the shallows survival
horror thriller the shallows seem to
come out of nowhere in 2016 going
certified fresh on Rotten Tomatoes the
predators stalking Blake Lively
throughout the film was created by
brilliantly named important-looking
pirates a Swedish VFX house that
specialized in sharks visual effects
supervisor Scottie Anderson told FS are
most animals sharks included are
designed to blend into the environment
our job is to use visibility selectively
to meet the needs of the
film and direct the audience and I when
we want or need to the purge election
year
visual effects veteran James hadn't has
worked on countless horror franchises
over the years but not have been quite
as timely as 2016's
the purge election year thanks to
Hadden's company VFX legion viewers were
able to experience another frightening
night on the lawless streets of a bleak
near future of merica though for the
actors involved many of those scenes
were created in post
according to Haddon his priority on a
project like this one is delivering
value for money
he told Fright find horror movies do not
have huge budgets and so the idea that
cg is going to be in your horror movie
it's really hard to do because they're
not funded to do that haddem went on to
explain that it's his personal policy to
make sure that any shots his company is
responsible for don't look cheap even if
they are cheap by blockbuster standards
adding my goal and delivering shots out
of VFX legion to the world is that they
should not bump in a cut from me theas a
number of VFX house has worked on Ridley
Scott's 2012 return to the Alien
franchise including MPC fueled VFX luma
pictures and wet a digital the new
zealand-based company was tasked with
rendering the film's new race of giant
humanoid extraterrestrials which
involved digitally enhancing the onset
performance of a costumed actor what
does VFX supervisor Martin Hill said
usually we would strive to make a
digi-key as anatomically accurate as
possible in terms of its musculature
articulation and the thickness and
pliability of the fat under the skin we
had to make some compromises to match an
actor in silicone prosthetics designing
the look of the engineers was a job that
felled a concept artist Neville page
he told Wired that when Scott first
approached him the director envisioned
the engineers as a mixture between some
well-known statues and one legendary
musician Page said Scott had specific
metaphors in mind for the artist telling
Wired I was looking at reference of
Statue of Liberty
the Michiel Angelou sculptures
specifically David and oddly Elvis
Pressley World War Z when he sat down to
discuss his team's achievements with
wired World War Z visual effects
supervisor Scott Farrar explained that
it was always their intention to break
from the traditional zombie mold with
this movie they went with a scientific
approach reckoning that a real virus of
this nature would make humans fast
vicious and relentless the biggest
example is the epic moment when 8500
computer animated zombies pile on top of
each other to breach the walls of Israel
Farrar said the single hardest thing
about that was just making those piles
look right without something going wrong
you're always battling with what looks
good and cool in a movie and still feels
real you can look at these shots every
day for months and then all of the
sudden you're almost ready to go to
Final and somebody will spot something
that's wrong in the shot it's like
Where's Waldo
while CGI clearly played a massive part
in bringing this world of live animation
director Andrew Jones favored a mixture
of computer graphics and practical
performances hiring talented
contortionists who could mimic the semi
possessed look they were going for
Krampus
to promote their work on the 2015
Christmas horror movie Krampus wetter
released a mock interview with the
film's chief gingerbread handler who
claimed
working with the gingerbread man on set
was a real challenge they were easily
startled fragile and real skittish in
reality they were one of the smaller
challenges what have faced on the
project which was approached in a
largely practical fashion for sake of
nostalgia when a workshop co-founder
Richard Taylor said this is a classic
eighties monster movie this is fantastic
stuff this is what we live for this is
what gets us up in the morning from the
animatronic cherub that attacks Toni
Collette in the Attic to the terrifying
jack-in-the-box operated from inside by
three puppeteers Krampus minions were as
ingenious as they were unnerving and
none more so than the anti-claus himself
the titular demon was portrayed by Luke
Hawker who wore a custom-made costume
complete with hoofs stilts and
prosthetic finger extensions he said of
the heavy suit the muscles are just
burning and you're sweating and you
think
am I gonna throw up and then what comes
in and his the smile on his face de
sizzle I am Legend the Will Smith led
adaptation of Richard Matheson's seminal
zombie novel I am Legend did pretty well
with the critics and didn't disappoint
at the box office but it's widely
accepted that the CGI suck the film was
fast-tracked into production before a
script had even been completed and the
schedule started to get backed up when
the practical creature effects looked
terrible on camera the decision was made
to render the undead digitally though in
reality there was never enough time to
make him look convincing
director Francis Lawrence told den of
geek it was better than doing the live
versions at that time because it didn't
work but we needed six more months on
the post end to get all the visual
effects right because there were some
close-ups that were stunning and then
you get some shots that I never got
right and it just kills it one of the
big downfalls for me with that movie
personally was with the visual effects
VFX supervisor Yannick Sears told awm
that the animators were still
redesigning the creatures during
post-production to match the quote
continually evolving nature of the film
deadly honeymoon even if you consider
yourself a true gore hound chances are
you've never heard of deadly honeymoon
this low-budget TV movie from 2010
probably would have flown under the
radar altogether had it not been based
on true events that took place five
years earlier a story that grabbed news
headlines and became the subject of a
Dateline report in 2005 newlywed George
Smith and his bride Jennifer set sail on
their dream honeymoon cruise though only
one of them would survive the groom
simply vanished one night a mystery that
has never been solved lifetime adapted
the story into a television feature
changing the names and creating their
own explanation they cast Summer Glau in
the role of wife turned widowed Lyndsey
which was a dream come true according to
the actress she told my San Antonio I've
wanted to do a Lifetime movie since I
was a little girl it's a really good way
for girls to get challenging dramatic
roles her faith in the network was
rewarded when they hired an experienced
VFX crew to turn the set in to the open
ocean thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to
[Music]